es una cuestión que se plantea en todo
el continente deben los países de la
unión europea hacer obligatorias las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 mientras la
variante omicron se extiende por europa
austria y alemania se han mostrado
favorables a la obligatoriedad la
comisión europea dijo el miércoles que
los países deberían estar abiertos al
debate
a ver cómo podemos fomentar y pensar
potencialmente en la vacunación
obligatoria dentro de la unión europea
esto necesita un debate esto necesita un
enfoque común pero es una discusión que
creo que tiene que ser dirigida a sting
hast villette en francia a las tasas de
vacunación son altas en torno al 75 por
ciento aunque 6 millones de personas aún
no se han vacunado algunos expertos
sostienen que lo importante no es
centrarse en obligar sino en convencer a
la gente de que se vacune en primer
lugar
báscolo visitado lo importante es
convencer a las personas de que se
vacunen lo antes posible ya sea la
primera la segunda o la tercera dosis
cada país de la unión europea ha
adoptado una postura diferente respecto
a la implantación de la vacuna el
secretario de sanidad de reino unido
dijo la semana pasada que no cree que
vayan a hacer obligatorias las vacunas
mientras que grecia es el primer país
que especifica un límite de edad con un
mandato para los mayores de 60 años la
tasa de vacunación en la unión europea
se sitúa en el 66 por ciento
aproximadamente un tercio de la
población